IT'S BEEN A WEEK
Last week I asked you to Diss track me
ohhhhhhhhh so scaaared
I'm SHAKING, shaking, I'm scARED.
That's a joke, by the way. I'm not actually scared.
This is me fake shaking
Because in reality
I'm CONfident in myself and my own abilities, that ANYTHING that will be said in this diss track
It's going to be a load of garbage. Now of course you guys are just idiots
I asked you to do a diss track and I get this. You laugh you lose Pewdiepie original cut . Great
haha hahahahahaha  What else do we got. Youtube border. haha. Wamen
Eh wait, it's an urban dictionary now? A rare species of wamen that usually need more attention slash
respect than other women also some of them are an idiot. "Is math related to science?"
ARE an idiot... okay good job *burp*
tihahahaha
I'll take that you know. He's a handsome man. He's a beautiful man.
Hey, his torso may be abnormally small, but goddamn
I'll take it alright. CAN WE GET to the GODDAMN diss tracks stop distracting me? Oh here we go. Here's the diss track
Okay, here we go
Okay doing th- doing the old READ OFF the phone thing
pewdiepie, you have ugly tits
Ugly what? what the HONK did he say?
PEWWWDIEPIE
lemme see those fugly tits
pewdiepie, you have ugly tats.
OOH HONK YOU.
you're HONK ugly.  How dare you.  you know what I don't even care.
Pewdipie you have an ugly ass.
Pewdiepie you have an ugly ass.
You haven't even SEEN it.
Shut the HONK up.
Lemme slap that ugly ass.
K this is kinda, kinky, and funky. I mean funky.
Pewdiepie, your beard is so nasty.
But i bet it's pretty tasty.
It is tasty
It is goddamn tasty, I put vanilla beard oil... ok
Pewdiepie, you respect wamen
Lemme suck yo HONK *snicker*
What the HONK fuck
OH Doland Dark made one. OH GOOD. Let's see what this meme, meme account dude
What are you my name a Jeff? Huh? Is that what you gon. Make a diss track on me
That's your next job is to submit your diss track on me
Oh, no, you better not yet, rice is a Pewdiepie
Beat is ass so hard, but he'll piss black. Oh, man. I've only just begun don't worry this videos not 1001
Pewdiepie also known as Felix Kjellberg I wish the titanic hit you are not the Iceberg. Oh
Are you doing here in the corner of the video in your little square?
God there goes another one. No originality you stole this from ryskamp. Oh?
Look, it's my favorite Chiba. He writes the beat about as well as nuba
There's the fat one
Acting again, how many reactions now seven eight nine ten this whole trend is really fucking lame
Why did I write this?
Now I'm literally just the same
if you're a Youtuber, please stop rapping
What's the point you've only got nine-Year-old clapping?
True, it's true
Damn, that was not that isn't even in a diss on me is desam the whole shitty district even like
Mainstream artists are buying into this now like Katy perry and taste way are just making these bad songs
They're just bad
Just make a decent song at least we're gonna make a diss track make it a decent song like this song is a lyrical genius
this song is
Mozart of our Modern Time Doland Darker more like Dolan
Mozar cuz it's good. It's really good
But just look like I'm an imprisoned isn't it they let me keep my jacket at least. Thank you
I mean following you for five years. Oh, that's so sweet. What a beautiful picture
That's when I actually looked attractive. Thank you very much. That's an amazing fan art can I get the diss tracks though?
lyrics in video :)
Now you step it over the line you see this
You you can't call my beard trash when you're looking like a ginger reject, okay?
What the fuck is that put them up next to each other okay? I'm sorry you just
illegitimize your entire diss track okay? I was on board for a minute, but God damn it. You just you trashed yourself you ruined yourself I'm sorry to say it
ok so pewdiepie sucks
He's so childish
he probably just makes videos for money and
I don't know. He's just so stupid
you know I'm just playing with you poods its all love <3
Okay, his beard does connect a lot better actually now that I see it
He does have this problem here that it doesn't go under sides. Why is the beard thing the only thing that bothers me that
Was good that was really good. Well done sage well done legit better than most of these diss tracks
Alright here. We go another diss track
Oh hi Felix. You smell like fish. How does a stupid ass swede get rich?
I don't smell like fish by the way, that's that's not accurate. I have to come clean here
JK I like pewdiepie JK again *HONK* pewdiepie
Who am I? Just call me  the guy dissing pewdiepie. Didn't wanna do it really truly
I don't enjoy breaking up this down, but the challenge was presented
So I'm gonna break the sound and infect it about to be in everybody's you to recommended
So wall street journal take notes and collective then the farm is a snaps king of the diss tracks coming at you
but i dont need 10 to convince that
Team 10? More like team 10 minutes
by the time i would feel like Marzia. Im glad its finished
Why would you? I have seen the same video time and time again on your page like here we go
Laugh or lose? Cmon pewdie really tho? Literally you laugh everytime theres a silly joke
Whats the point?
Oh ya its almost like jokes are made to be laughed at. Oh that's really *HONK* weird
You struggling for content? So you say make a diss track what a concept
I make the fans make videos to pewds. Make them do the work and reupload it back to you
And i gotta give you credit you a clever dude
Why? Cuz im writing this track now. You better choose
batty fat snaps or i smack you in the knee caps
Im your worst nightmare triple bad as 3pac
And he's making stuff way better than you ever did so send your army. I'm ready for the masses
Master with the verbs of professor teaching classes
The best is to run the when and you know this then you don't agree then you people
Are you smell like fish? Is that that's the chorus, but you smell
okay, so wait so you do raps right and
You completely stole the flow of Eminem good good job good job. That's really impressive. I'm really impressed by your rap skills. I'm sure
Keep keep doing that and I'm sure you'll go big places take back about what you said about me smelling like a fish
If you're gonna rhyme outwits then don't pronounce it wrong. I'm nitpicking. I love Pewdiepie
Now you don't know you don't how dare you say that?
Good me
Yes, well, then that's awesome
Alright another 15, so that's why I both look you didn't have to tell me that I can see that from your pimple
Yes, face, bring it run - shit
oh
No, he's got that M&M poster. Let's talk about this motherfucker, Pewdiepie you probably heard of this Youtube guy fuck a million
But you million for video epic meal time looking at so here. We go. PB five become one with the tryna
Tell a couple inches no original thought the knees evan on the layers
Just killing effort really. He's run out of an easily become a goal
Every single Fuckin video became an Aussie and last year he showed
He moved out of the club piece to do ever since then your channels Benign show, fro
This is really hip throw all these days tracks because you but if it's no beauty Pod
Even though your channels dying you still managed to get me to click on your lies
I don't know why I really wanna die your content so she it makes me Wanna, cry I
Mean good flow this guy had good flow I got a for a fifteen-year-old that's pretty good. All right. What do we got? Oh?
Grande did one. What is a it's your host killer keemstar and today?
I'll be reporting the for a beauty part 0 deaths won't be true when I'm done with this friend
Norman Shaw but
I have zero respect. Here's a question where did the original
Content go if you run out of ideas like three years ago
You laugh you lose. I'm gonna make you fire and lose make fun of you
Now you're all over the news thanks, and I heard you are an asset. What's wrong with you
Stretching to ten minutes for Braddock's and revered like no one's at your stage
Not least thanks to you
scaring
Advertisers are where scare Pewdiepie?
No one wants it anyway, naturally by being more family-Friendly
Well, too bad none of your videos are comedy friendly. Oh, you spent rigid spheres think that makes you cool
Yeah, it's not like you're starting fires in your backyard home. Oh
well, I guess I got a
Great that lemus dead, please stop who in their right mind would think old memes are still funny?
Jk, Pewdiepie, I love you are there much I was fuckin awesome. Well, then it's one got a lot of dislike
Sorry, I imagine it's really good for the game
When they're grown sorry, it's a bit different
Which I appreciate didn't make my card or anything
But you know sorry for real really appreciate you guys making these I love watching this stuff. It's really fun
I'm glad I have an army of people that can just make original content for me. Well. I just react to it. I
Know that's like a meme, but at the same time. It's pretty cool. What should we do for next week?
What's next week Challenge, huh?
Make something physical not just a painting or a drawing or some something like that make something out in the real world
Out there and take a picture of it and send it to me
And I will judge it from a scale from one to ten
Most likely you will not get a ten but I will accept any challenge
Show the impact of the squad Fam in the world it could be a video
It could be a picture it could be anything you like baby
But that's it for me for now. Leave a like if you enjoyed watching squad fam out